Scott Disick is finally giving Kourtney  Kardashian what she's always wanted the  33 year old reality star and his ex have  been in a great place since their  breakup over a year ago  a source tells et for the past two  months Scott has been on his best  behavior and hasn't been drinking or  partying something Kourtney has always  wanted for him it's just so not like you  though there are reports stating the  former couple has rekindled their  romantic relationship a source tells ET  the rumors are quote completely untrue  but to spend plenty of time together  with their kids but the source says  quote she is not going to forget years  of tears and heartbreak because he is on  a six-week streak they are not back  together the parents of Mason Penelope  and rain don't do much to dispel the  rumors just last month  Scott posted this cheeky pic of court  while the pair were on a family vacation  in Mexico we wanted you guys to hear  first  [Music]  you